(audience cheers)
- But first, give it up, one
more time for My Band Y'all.
(audience claps and cheers)
And as you can see,
we have a very special
guest with us this hour.
He's part of the legendary
rock group that wrote,
"Gimme some money".
From Spinal Tap, it's
Derek Smalls everybody.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
Thank you so much for
celebrating Rad Mom Hour with us.
We're so excited to have him,
we're excited to have you
here, just so you know.
- Very excited to be here.
- They're excited to be here.
I just want you to talk the whole time.
Do you have a rad mom?
(mumbles)
- My mom left.
We call it a mum in Britain.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- It's like mum's the word.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Language.
She left when I was four
to join an old girl band.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- So, that's kind of rad.
It's rad, right out of town.
- Left at four, that's hard.
That's a...
There's a whole hour for that show.
(audience laughs)
We need to have...
Well, you have a solo album out as well.
- Yes, it's called "Smalls Change".
(audience claps and cheers)
- [Kelly] Okay, yes!
- 'Cause I'm not with the
band, so that's the change
and I'm Smalls, so that's the idea.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- Love you!
So, with Derek sitting
in with My Band, all hour
and they'll be playing some
of Spinal Tap's greatest hits
around the commercial breaks.
It's a rad band for a
bunch of bad mammas, y'all.
(audience cheers)
Let's talk with the mama who requested
that first Spinal Tap
hit "Gimme some money".
It's actually actress and
musician, Zooey Deschanel.
So-
(audience cheers)
Yeah, yeah.
- Hi! Hi! Hi!
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
So, why did you request that song?
And also you look amazing and adorable.
- Oh my God! Thank you so much.
So listen,
this is gonna sound like a fake story.
(audience laughs)
But it's a hundred percent real.
I lived on a tropical island
in the middle of the Indian
ocean when I was a child.
And there were only two
movies that you could rent
from the video store-
- Just two?
- Which was like,
it was just a corner
of like the only store
that was on this island.
(audience laughs)
Okay.
And the two videos were,
"This is Spinal Tap"
and one half of the movie
"Gandhi" with Ben Kingsley.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
And I was seven years old
so, of course Spinal Tap was
more appealing than Gandhi.
So, I watched Spinal Tap probably,
I don't know, a thousand times.
And it would be,
it's really hard to
choose like a favorite hit
but this one, just a
classic Derek, huge fan.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- So excited to be here.
- Is there-
(audience claps)
- [Zooey] But can I-
- Is there anything you wanna ask Derek?
- I do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually, sorry.
- [Kelly] Oh, she's coming
down, y'all. She's coming down.
(audience cheers)
- So, I don't know.
I mean, hey! Hey! Hey!
I'm not allowed to hug you but
- I know it's COVID.
- Like, do you really need money?
'Cause like-
- Do you really need-
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- [Derek] Oh!
- I just... I brought it
just in case, you know,
'cause I knew I was going to
request. (Kelly laughs loudly)
I mean, I just thought.
- Zooey, since you're here.
- It's a-
Oh! Thank you.
(audience cheers)
I gave him some money!
- Yeah, you gave him money!
(audience cheers)